hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank the podcast where John and Hank
green answer your questions provide
dubious advice and share with you all of
the vital news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon yeah welcome we're gonna have
a good time - are we gonna have a good
time today I just want to make sure I
think we're gonna have a good time but
as comedy podcasts go Hank it it might
get dark that's what that's how we like
it
uh can I start today with a short poem a
very very short poem that would please
me greatly
um can I look up the short poem that I
uh I got a I got to find a short poem
real quick Hank um you forgot about that
part I forgot about that part but
fortunately I am a veritable fount of
short poems it's at founder font you're
the writer
anyway this poem is by Mary Oliver from
her wonderful book A Thousand mornings
it's called I go down to the shore I go
down to the shore in the morning and
depending on the hour the waves are
rolling in or moving out and I say oh I
am miserable
what shall what should I do and the sea
says in its lovely voice excuse me I
have work to do Mary Oliver her poem I
go down to the shore from her book a
thousand mornings and it brings us
nicely to our first question Hank in
this hilarious comedy podcast is from an
anonymous listener who lives with
chronic back pain and has been for many
years and quote I have been told I need
to accept it and keep moving forwards
and I'm sure the people telling me this
are right but moving past it is
difficult because it's not like a linear
thing like when my parents got divorced
I could accept it and move on because
there was a linear point that I could
move away from it happened it sucked I
can deal with it and put space between
it and me and not have it crushed me but
pain is different it's part of me it's
stuck with me probably forever as there
are a few options for me at this point
you've both struggled with chronic pain
and I was curious
how you have gone this far because it
really is awful
it's a great question and one that is
one that I think about a lot especially
when I'm in pain the first thing that I
would recommend Hank is reading this
book that I don't know if you've read
but it's my favorite book on the topic
of pain it's called the body in pain by
Elaine scar II are you familiar with it
I am NOT it's like an academic book and
it can be dense at times but at the very
beginning she makes this brilliant
observation that completely clarified
all of my thoughts about physical pain
which is that to be in pain yourself is
to have certainty and to observe or hear
about the pain of others is to have
doubt because you can never really
understand what other people's pain
looks like or feels like whereas when
you are having pain yourself it is this
you know absolute undeniable certainty
I remember hearing I think it was on a
podcast probably Radiolab about how
awful our pain scales are and how like
they don't they're not very useful when
someone goes into the doctor and the
doctor says you know tell me your pain
on a scale of one to ten like what
people self-report is not is not helpful
at all and many people experiencing more
pain will that's lower on the scale
because they can think of things that
are much more painful than the thing
they're experiencing right now what
tends to be more helpful and this is was
really interesting was having people say
what would you give up to get rid of
your pain mm would you like it would you
get a really bad haircut to get rid of
your pain or would you take ten years
off your life to get rid of your pain
right and I actually have a friend who
has been studying the the sort of not
just the human lifespan but this new
sort of concept of like can we measure
sort of global quality of health not
just not just amount of life but quality
of life and pain is is very high and and
chronic back pain in particular is the
sort of thing that that that they in
their research look at as something that
it takes away a significant amount of of
like liveable years and is it's sort of
similar like one year of living with
chronic back pain and in their research
the way that they measure that is kind
of like saying like it's sort of like
75% of a healthy year right and so it's
it's very difficult I think to to
communicate that to people who have not
had that pain and I certainly have not
had that pain and and all of my pain has
had the potential of going away someday
and that hope is very powerful and and
when that hope is not there whether
that's whether that's a real lack of
hope and that there really is nothing
that can be done even you know with
fingers crossed cart bike future
research but or if that hope is is just
because it becomes very difficult to
hope when you are in serious pain that's
very difficult yeah there's a great
David Foster Wallace line that I'm
probably going to butcher in Infinite
Jest where it's he's talking about
psychic pain but a character points out
that that no single moment is unbearable
it's the collection of all past moments
combined with the pain of the present
moment
combined with hopelessness about ever
being free from this pain in all future
moments that's so unbearable so what I
guess I would encourage this person to
think about or what I find helpful is
you know things like a talking to
not just traditional doctors but also
psychologists and psychiatrists about
pain and pain management and be trying
to live in now instead of
catastrophizing and assuming that this
pain can never get better I know that's
incredibly I mean I know from personal
experience that's incredibly difficult
to do on a minute-by-minute basis but
that's the only way I've ever found any
kind of like peace or relief inside of
physical pain the other frustrating
thing about physical pain is that it
defies language like it's very difficult
to
scribe pane I have a theory that one of
the reasons we invented metaphors in the
first place was as a way of dealing with
physical pain because you can't describe
it except metaphorically it's like an
ice pick behind my eye it's uh it's like
uh being stabbed in my jaw it's like you
know it's always like something it
always yeah I have some I have some
chronic pain in my leg and I it's taken
me a long time to be able to describe it
and what I say now and what it actually
does feel like is someone is is rubbing
my muscle with sandpaper it's not like
the worst possible feeling but that's
what it feels like it's like a hot
friction someone is grabbing and and
rubbing the bottom part of my quadricep
with sandpaper and like to me it's like
yeah that's exactly what it feels like
and people are like oh okay that sounds
awful there's some communicability in
the power of metaphor when it comes to
pain yeah but still I think that
ultimately pain does defy language and
and you know hopefully all I can hope
for you is that you're surrounded by
people who love you and who understand
that your pain is real and and and
please know that it that it is real you
never have to doubt that you never have
to doubt that what you're experiencing
is is true yeah and going to see a
psychiatrist or a psychologist does not
mean that you're going to get your your
your psychological pain treated it means
that you are going to to find ways to
deal with your real pain yep you got to
find psychological ways to deal with
physical pain when there are no physical
solutions to physical pain duh boy it's
another hilarious start to this comedic
podcast all right let's move on to a
question from Olivia who asks Dear John
and Hank if there was an epic battle
between Gandalf and Dumbledore who would
win and why okay I mean I've got nothing
against Dumbledore uh he's his this is
not a diesel coming and he's powerful
and he knows a lot of stuff and he's not
afraid to manipulate small children and
use them in pawns in his deadly games to
protect she's a fantastic headmaster of
a boardings yes well I mean he's more
than that
ah he's more than that he's he's trying
to save the
world at least britain as far as I can
tell it's weird how that sort of the
effects of whatever weirdness is
happening in the Harry Potter will never
reach his past the boundaries of a very
small island but Dumbledore is just a
human who has some special powers and
he's been trained in the magical arts
Gandalf is not that is not what wizards
are in middle-earth Gandalf is a God
essentially well he's more of an angel
he's he's an angel he like sort of
create what it was created by God he's
like a direct creation of Aluva tar the
god of middle-earth he made him so the
question of who would win a epic battle
between Gandalf and Dumbledore to me
there is only one answer it's obviously
Gandalf Hank and I agree about this but
Hank let me ask you a secondary question
that I think is gonna be a little more
difficult for you yes yes if you could
either be Gandalf or Dumbledore who
would you want to be oh no I don't feel
like I have a simple answer to that
question oh I do it's easy this is not a
difficult question the answer is
Dumbledore it's better to be Dumbledore
every day of the week it's better to be
Dumbledore for one thing just life is
better life is life is better for
Dumbledore than it is for Gandalf for
another thing you have better company he
does seem to have a much better time and
Gandalf smokes and I find smoking a
despicable reprehensible habit and
something that Dumbledore would never
take yeah Dumbledore just eats candy a
lot yeah exactly would you rather be a
guy who can blow very fancy smoke rings
or just a guy who enjoys candy but you
know I think Gandalf has a good time too
he seems like when things are going okay
he seems like a jolly guy you know he
like has fun fireworks shows and he
hangs out with the hobbits and does cool
stuff people like him let me submit that
things are rarely going okay over there
whereas at Hogwarts things are often
fairly good well you also have to look
at where each of them is at the end of
the story and we won't talk any more
about that
well yeah I guess on that front there
there is a there is a front-runner let's
move on Hank - a great question oh I
realize I'm asking all the questions
maybe I you never let me ask questions
all right
so Sofia says dear Hank and John what
type of apocalypse would you most like
to happen no kind I would prefer a zero
kind of apocalypse I just don't like
what mmm why does there have to be an
apocalypse no I don't I want my
apocalypse to be the heat death of the
universe the inevitable unavoidable
moment when there is no more
distribution of energy unequally
throughout throughout space-time which
is going to happen but it's the longest
time it could possibly take well Hank
you'll be surprised to learn that I am
looking forward to the apocalypse and
spend a lot of time thinking about it I
actually own the cambridge encyclopedia
of eschatology which is the study of
people's thoughts about the end of the
world and I have a tremendous amount of
what's called eschatological anxiety
worried about the end of the world I'm a
big believer in in in in at least human
the human apocalypse coming in the form
of a you know not not a bang but a
whimper I think there will be a series
of sort of like minor bangs over the
period of like maybe the next 5,000
years and then will be reduced to like
maybe 10,000 mating pairs and then we'll
just kind of fight it out until there's
none of us left
well done at 10,000 mating pairs you
really have the opportunity to do the
whole thing over again but we won't why
not yeah it's just not like us um I want
to say a couple things first I've never
heard the word eschatological and I like
it and I like that it includes the word
scat it makes me think of poop and it
makes me think of that wonderful musical
genre or musical technique well if you
looked at the if you looked at the word
in a dictionary you would see that it in
fact does not contain the words is but
I was it spelled there Q is an esq you a
th ah esque eschatological you didn't
make it very funny you didn't make it
very funny needed to say Hank did not
participate in the Scripps Howard
Spelling Bee eschatology is not a hard
word to spell I've never heard it well
it is a it is a Christian specific term
and you come from a broader religious
background so the other thing I want to
say is when I was in college I wrote a
song called Rome didn't fall in a day
yeah because everyone says rome wasn't
built in a day and then everybody looks
at uh everybody looks at America or or
Rome and says like you know how like and
and sort of the imagined crash comes
like immediate and and like in a matter
of days or weeks or months when really
that's not how it works Rome took
hundreds of years to fall and and so did
all great empires for the most part so I
mean in fact you could argue that there
was something of a Roman Empire until
like World War one I mean it all depends
on how you define romina sand and you
could argue that there's a Roman Empire
now seated in the in at the Vatican City
that extends uh you know I mean
beginnings and ends in general are
extremely undramatic I found this with
almost without exception because
everything that seems like it's going to
be an event turns out to be a process
everything that seems like it's going to
be a revelation turns out to be like
something that happens over years yes uh
we've got a question from Kathy this is
a very important question Dear John and
Hank it's hot I am too hot what are some
good ways to cool off I have a song
about this you do it's called it's too
hot
yes it's called it's too hot I have a
song about everything apparently the at
the end of the world
I should write more songs about the end
of the world I sure do talk about it
applies podcast is sponsored by Hanks
songs available now at dftba.com Thank
You Hank songs for your continuing
patronage of our little podcast today's
podcast is also brought to you by the
fall of the Roman Empire
fire it took not it wasn't an immediate
process it took many hundreds of years
and lots and lots of people died
thank you fall of the Roman Empire for
your support of the world as it is today
I'd love to thank our sponsor for
today's podcast the Archduke Franz
Ferdinand whose assassination in 1914
sparked World War one the event that
once and for all ended any argument over
whether there was still a roman empire
sponsoring this podcast
Gavrilo Princip who shot the Archduke
Franz Ferdinand after walking out of a
sandwich shop because he really didn't
like the idea of the austro-hungarian
Empire and we'd also like to think the
Archduke Franz Ferdinand's idiot uncle
the Emperor Franz Josef who never even
really liked his nephew but still got
angry enough about the assassination to
go ahead and start world war one
thanks for sponsoring our podcast
Emperor Franz Joseph of the now
non-existent austro-hungarian Empire
let's not include this I'm not sure how
much of that is going to end up in the
podcast but in case you got cut at some
point Hagen I just spent 20 minutes
going back and forth trying to prove
which of us knew more about the start of
World War 1 oh I know a great deal about
the start of World War 1 yeah so do I
that's why it took 20 minutes for us to
have the debate okay um Hank if I could
go back to the question which is not
about the start of World War one but
instead about the fact that it is
currently hot outside at least in much
of the northern hemisphere uh what are
some good ways to cool off you can go
and get some ice cubes and put them in
your pants there you have lady town okay
I don't think there's a need for a
second for a second piece of advice that
that should suffice so there you have it
Kathy another thing that I used to do
even though I know that that's the only
piece of advice we really need to share
is I used to put my hat in the freezer
every night and I would wake up in the
morning and put my hat on that's a good
idea yeah that's when I lived in Chicago
I find that in general just at having
having something cold is extremely
helpful you wouldn't really think it but
just like holding on to a cold
thing cools down your whole body quite a
lot there's a lot of blood vessels in
your hand Hank speaking of your
knowledge of science we've got a
question from James who writes dear John
and Hank if the universe has no edge how
is it expanding ah it's a great question
I have no idea because I do not
understand even after it has been
explained to me by both my brother and
Neil deGrasse Tyson how the universe can
possibly not have an edge if it is also
expanding what is it expanding into so
take your shirt and stretch it okay I've
got it stretch your shirt just so you
know Hank I'm wearing an AFC Wimbledon
shirt I'm stretching it I'm wearing an
Andrew Huang shirt so you're stretching
it and in the well who loves Mars not
you stretch it and there's a there's
that the fabric doesn't sew like
ignoring certain things the fabric
doesn't expand into anything it just
expands it just gets bigger disagree
that the fabric expands into the air
I'll think about the air just think
about the fabric if the fabric were all
of space-time if the fabric were three
dimensional and four dimensional then
then it would just be expanding and it
wouldn't be expanding into anything it
will just be getting with more space
between it right okay that's a great
that's a great explanation I really
appreciate it I still have a couple of
questions the first thing is that when I
expand when I expand my shirt I can't
help but notice that my shirt has an
edge I'm holding it right now in its
most expanded capacity and there does
seem to be an edge of it and after the
shirt there is um what I would call air
well imagine MIT but right but the the
fact that there is an edge to the shirt
does not affect how the shirt expands if
you if you had an infinite piece of
shirt and you stretched it what would
happen OTT imagine the first of asking
me to imagine an infinite piece of shirt
is a big ask I would
just having this conversation with my
five-year-old son actually because he
said that he was having an argument at
camp over whether infinity was the
biggest number or whether infinity plus
one was the biggest number and I had to
explain to him that first off not all
infinities are of the same size and
secondly infinities is not a number like
infinity is not a very large number it's
it's just a countless Ness yeah
it and so you're asking me to imagine an
infinite shirt right yes all right I
think I have it and then stretch stretch
the shirt I'm stretching it so what
happened uh well first off I can't
notice that even in my mind the infinite
shirt does have edges but I know that
that is a weakness of my mind because
the infinite shirt can't have edges
because the infinite shirt is not very
very big it's infinite which is
different from very very big so I'm
trying to train my mind to imagine that
okay now the infinite shirt is
stretching so two points two points on
that infinite shirt just got farther
apart that two points on that infinite
shirt got farther apart quick question
what did that infinite shirt expand into
I think that the problem is not with the
expanding I think it is with the
infinite I think that is that's the part
that we really have a hard time with
because because it doesn't need to have
expanded into anything because it was
infinite it can't expand anything it
can't expand into anything it was
already as big as it can be so what
you're saying is that the universe
doesn't have an edge because it's
infinite and it's able to expand but
there's nothing on the other side of
that expanse because it has no edge kind
of yeah
oh man I mean there's not there's not an
expanse to be on the other side of oh my
god this is such a funny comedy podcast
um Amy asks dear Hank and John why do we
have individual fingerprints what
practical purpose could they possibly
have evolved to serve I know the actual
answer
of question the job do you want to take
a guide you want to take a guess Hank
thank you for the opportunity we evolved
individually distinct fingerprints so
that every person could grip slightly
different objects well that is my guess
is that correct I mean no but I love it
I love the idea that like that like this
just over the broad spectrum of humanity
there's a person that can hold
everything perfectly like like right no
there's not there's one person there's
only one person who has the perfect
fingerprints for the iPhone set and
there's only one person who has the
perfect fingerprint to like I don't know
hold a Trillium flower there's only one
person who has the perfect fingerprint
to to hold the particular Club that
killed the first Mastodon yeah okay I
love you I love it um the answer is that
fingerprints are there because they help
us grip things they increase the surface
area of our of the of our fingers and
and they do increase the friction
between our fingers and surfaces so
they're they're helpful so I was right I
was right you're welcome I like rubbing
sure listening for like you're the tops
of your fingers on your desk and then
rubbing the bottoms of your fingers on
your desk the your bought your
fingertips will stick more and as for
why we evolved to have individual
different fingerprints every person has
different fingerprints we didn't evolve
to have different fingerprints that is
just a weird consequence of how
fingerprints are made when we are in the
womb and partially or or Jai was right
one of those two things are the truth
Hank if the universe has no edge how is
it extending exactly like how what is it
expanding into this question is from
Erik Erik says dear Hank and John I just
got my first job as a go-kart
maintenance person I don't know the
actual job title and I'm feeling the
pressure with school and Friends I'm
having trouble balancing at all how did
you manage to transition into the
workforce from your first jobs first off
Eric let me just say that as first jobs
go go-kart maintenance person is
amazing it's pretty cool I mean you're
learning about people because you've got
to work with customers but you're also
learning about engineering and you're
also probably learning about like
co-workers and managers it's like to me
it's like the perfect first job also I
am a massive go-kart enthusiast Hank do
you know about my go-kart enthusiasm
it's an extension of my love for
racecars yeah yeah a little bit yeah I
love go-karts they're amazing uh I don't
know what was your first John think I
don't remember Walmart oh right Walmart
yeah you did the carts yeah I did the
carts among other things I did find it
difficult to manage my social life and
my academic obligations alongside my
early jobs I worked at a warehouse and
then I worked at Steak and Shake and a
couple other restaurants um I think the
key for me was understanding that my job
in some ways had to come last like I
needed to be there when I needed to be
there and I needed to pay attention into
a reasonably good job but in terms of my
emotional energy that needed to go
toward my friends and my family and my
academics I actually what luckily enough
worked with a lot of my friends at
Walmart so there was there was a bit of
a social component to it and in fact
that is why I worked at that Walmart
there was a closer Walmart to my house
that I chose not to work out because I
didn't know anyone who worked there and
I think that a lot of people have good
social experiences at work and I don't
know if that is an option open to you at
your go-kart place but but it might be
worth exploring and yeah I mean I'll
tell you what from my Steak and Shake
experience sometimes it is not worth the
floorings because as you know Hank my
main coworker he murdered someone and
now he's in prison but that's a story
for a different podcast table I have a
poem that is is relevant to this uh I
can't wait you're such a great reader
and student of poetry I cannot wait to
learn what what poem is relevant it's
very relevant it's by kenneth koch
it's called you want a social life with
friends oh you only know about this poem
because of me probably I was introduced
to this I have to say I was introduced
to this poem by Amy Kraus Rosenthal and
it's on my list for four short poems to
use in future podcasts but go ahead use
it now Hank I know about this poem
because Alan low stuff did a kinetic
typography video to it it is called you
want a social life with friends by
Kenneth Koch you want a social life with
friends a passionate love life and as
well to work hard every day what's true
is that of these three you may have two
and two may pay you dividends but never
may have three yeah I'm afraid that
might be true I mean it's it's
definitely difficult to balance all of
the things and there are other things to
balance too like there's your personal
health which becomes a bigger deal as
you get older like make like maintaining
that and there's you know family
obligations and making sure that you
take care of the people who have taken
care of you and like there's lots of
lots of balance there's also a game of
Thrones which is on every Sunday and if
you miss it even by like two hours
Twitter spoils it for you so there's so
there's a lot to manage in this life and
it's not easy but I would just encourage
you to always try to watch the shows
that you love live because otherwise
people will ruin them for you sorry what
are we talking about time management is
hard Hank do you ever pause to consider
the fact that our Father uh worked on
fishing boats in Alaska and like it is
difficult to perceive to like see that
in my mind's eye yet any like mushed
dogs in Alaska and he hiked most of the
Appalachian Trail and he like froze
camping in the Grand Canyon and look at
us just a couple of guys sitting in
comfortable chairs it's a very nice
chair actually my dad bought this chair
for me it took me to the to the office
store and he was like you're getting a
real chair dude you know it's funny
about that mom bought my chair for me
she even paid for it it was my 27th
birthday present this lazy boy that I'm
sitting in right now it may have been my
27th birthday present oh man what we
didn't know that 27 with was was chair
birthday all you 27 year olds out there
make sure to ask your parents for a very
special birthday gift chair chairs are
very important to your happiness okay
one more question before we get to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon the
most important portion of the podcast
this is from a 12 year old harine
hypothetically how much would it cost to
move AFC Wimbledon the greatest football
club in the history of the world to Mars
a cold dead Rock in the vacuum of space
for a day how much would it cost Hank to
move AFC Wimbledon to Mars for a day and
I'm going to go ahead I'm gonna give you
uh I'm gonna I'm gonna help you out with
some numbers okay oh wow we're not going
to move AFC Wimbledon's stadium that's
unreasonable and we're not going to move
anything Ness we're not going to move
anything more than is absolutely
necessary for AFC Wimbledon to play a
match on Mars right so that is a goal 11
players including Auto bio Aachen
phenoix uh and the manager Neil Ardley
along with you know all the clothes and
the cleats necessary to play soccer on
Mars
those are your requirements Hank how
much would it cost to move AFC Wimbledon
to Mars for one day uh how many players
are there on AFC Wimbledon well we I
think we're going to go ahead and not
bring any substitutes um
and so just the eleven eleven starters
eleven yeah a goalkeeper in ten outfield
players do have you just never watched a
soccer game in your entire life
so how are they are they gonna play a
game or they can they play like like
five on five or something no they're
going to play against a team that
that didn't that lives on mark you're
gonna yeah they're gonna play against a
team that is currently on Mars okay and
they're the can they only go for a day
or can they stay for a while is it
cheaper to stay yes what can you briefly
explain to me why it is cheaper to stay
on Mars than it is to just come and go
because you have to sort of launch at
the time when earth is closest and so
when we when we launch the earth mission
it will be at a time when earth is
closest to Mars and by the time they get
there earth will be far away from Mars
so you have to wait for Earth to get
close again Wow alright so we will amend
hareem's question AFC wimbledon will be
taking a how long how long what kind of
what kind of Mars I don't I don't know
like probably a year by now 30 months
probably months months Hank AFC
Wimbledon has a game every single
Saturday you can't we can't take months
away what what will happen to our
position in league two with autobuyer
walking phenoix on Mars instead of
playing in any in England
sorry I'm getting upset I sometimes
stutter when I'm upset I bet we could
get like sort of the cost down to like
one and a half billion per person
million or billion I find that question
funny its billion with a be billion with
a be per person it's a long it's a long
trip you think the cost of moving AFC
Wimbledon to Mars would be 1.5 billion
dollars per person times 11 is uh god
I'm so bad at math what is it sixteen or
at work at work at sixteen point five
billion dollars is your proposal for
getting AFC Wimbledon to Mars does that
include the notes hat seems low that
seems low to me now that I've there you
said it out loud well I also I forgot
Neil I forgot Neil Ardley the manager so
that's 18 billion yes okay uh if any of
our listeners have more precise
information on how much it would cost to
get AFC Wimbledon to Mars go ahead and
send us emails with your calc
at Hank and John at gmail.com that's
also where you can email us your
questions thank you to hurry man
everybody who asked a question today
Hank it's time for the news from Mars
what's going on in Mars these days
geologists have discovered glass on Mars
which is not in itself super surprising
because glass is formed here on earth
when meteorites impact the earth so uh
it is it was likely that glass would be
around on Mars that the news however is
though that they are able to for the
first time detect where there's a lot of
glass on the surface of Mars from orbit
using using some spectroscopy techniques
that are brand new and the cool thing
about that potentially is that here on
earth when glass is formed by natural
events you can actually it actually
captures some of the atmosphere in the
glass and so you can look inside the
glass and see what what the atmosphere
was like when that glass formed on earth
which gives us a little bit of insight
into the history of our planet and that
will also potentially give us insight
into the history of Mars which is great
because a lot of the ways that we here
on earth figure out you know what the
world was like a long time ago might not
work as well on Mars but this should
work just fine and could potentially
tell us if one day in the distant past
Mars had life on it Hank a quick
question you're saying that glass
contains the history of the atmosphere
from when it was made
yeah like traps little little bubbles of
air I mean I like to make fun of your
Mars news but that is actually pretty
awesome news dang it
I never know what you're gonna be
excited about III really don't
that's fascinating well I think that my
favorite thing about it is that unlike
most of your Mars news it actually is
happening on Mars um so then the news
the news from AFC Wimbledon this week
Hank as you know AFC Wimbledon is a club
that was formed by a group of fans after
Wimbledon FC departed for the town that
shall not be named in the greatest
scandal in the history of English
football it's a fan owned club a fan
controlled club but it's also a very
charity oriented club they have a great
foundation the AFC Wimbledon Foundation
and they also partner frequently with an
organization called Warchild which is a
organization that works with children
who are refugees from war or living in
places of conflict a great organization
based in the UK and right now if you
google AFC Wimbledon earphones or AFC
Wimbledon yeah just Google AFC Wimbledon
earphones you can get these amazing AFC
Wimbledon earphones that I'm actually
using to talk to you right now Hank
they've got a great mic on them and the
sound quality is excellent and the the
money raised is split between Warchild
and AFC Wimbledon foundation I mentioned
this in no small part Hank because you
are not currently using earphones with a
mic on them and it makes podcasting
unnecessarily difficult so I have bought
you a pair and I've also bought a pair
for everybody who asked a question that
was used on today's podcast but they're
really great I'm genuinely great
earphones and they got the little AFC
Wimbledon logo on them which is cool too
but it's a great way to support charity
so AFC Wimbledon launched that this week
and I wanted to let you know about it
and the history of that and everything
else will apparently be trapped inside
of my window so that's cool there's
probably a lot less air trapped inside
of your your window then and naturally
formed glass
that that is formed in pretty chaotic
circumstances not so much like the way
that your window glass is formed your
really harsh it on my buzz here Hank
um sorry about that you can that's kind
of that's kind of the Hank green story
though um I have some like Hank tells me
a little bit about science I make some
kind of broad metaphorically resonant
conclusion about it and then Hank is
like yeah but no not actually um if you
have a question for us again please
email us at Hank and John at gmail.com
an email address clearly invented by
Hank and thanks again for listening to
our podcast what have we learned today
Hank I'll give this we learned that we
learned a lot about the history of of
the beginning of World War one thanks to
our sponsor for this podcast and and the
fall of the Roman Empire
not to mention the fact that we learned
the importance of putting ice cubes in
your pants and the fact that we'd rather
be Dumbledore than Gandalf
at least until book mm5 nope nope
yeah yeah at least until foot 5 thanks
for listening and as we say in our
hometown of nerdfighteria don't forget
to be off don't forget to uh so hard to
do when you're doing it don't forget to
be awesome